Remember, when we start this problem we always start this by identifying our
unknown and in this case it was the angle. We don't know the angle, so we call
it x. Next we want to identify an equation in words. The supplement of an angle
is 40 more than twice its complement. These words actually represents our
equation. We have the supplement on the left and 40 more than twice the
complement on the right. This word is often serves as the word equals. This
allows us to set the supplement equal to 40 more than twice the compliment. The
supplement of our unknown angle would be 180 minus x, and the compliment of our
unknown angle would be 90 minus x. Now we solve this equation like before. We
distribute the positive 2 to get 180 minus 2x. Then we combine like terms to get
220. Next, we add 2x to both sides and we get 180 plus x equals 220. I've
rewritten this statement over here and my last step, I just subtract 180 from
both sides. So x is 40 degrees. If you got that one right, great work. You've
really come a long way in understanding equations and expressions. This stuff is
pretty tough. The last thing we want to do is make sure our answer is correct.
The supplement of 40 degrees is 140 degrees, since these two add up to 180. And
the compliment of our angle is 50 degrees. So let's compare these results with
what we've started with. Is this complement 40 more than twice our supplement?
If I double the complement, I get 100 degrees. And if I add 40 to it, I get 140
degrees. So, yeah, that's my supplement.